[Música]
80 años después de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial el muro del Atlántico se fisura
poco a poco vestigio de la ocupación
8000 block House a lo largo del océano
desde Noruega hasta el Sur de Francia
abandonados ante los elementos sin
embargo ha sido posible sacar provecho
de este legado de concreto en la punta
de San Martín al final de finister un
joven bretón tuvo la idea de crear un
museo en un búnker semi enterrado otrora
punto estratégico para las defensas
alemanas Si estamos en el comando de la
batería de artillería más imponente de
finister disparaban a 30 kilómetros a la
redonda aquí nos encontramos en la
entrada de la Ensenada de brest entonces
ello permitiría impedirle a cualquier
embarcación inglesa o norteamericana un
ingreso forzado al puerto de brest de
niño aurelion encontró en el ático de la
casa familiar el uniforme de vuelo este
hallazgo generó una verdadera pasión y
durante años El joven recorrió el campo
bretón buscando objetos y testimonios
actualmente expuestos en este lugar
cargado de historia
[Música]
testimonios desgarradores que reían
obtuvo de sobrevivientes marcados por el
conflicto
hay pequeños momentos Mágicos en estos
encuentros ocurre cuando la persona nos
cuenta una anécdota algo que vivió que
pudo haber durado tan solo unos segundos
pero que lleva con ella Desde entonces
ahí todo quedó cristalizado
están las emociones de la época
sabe describirnos el contexto el entorno
Cómo era Todos los detalles
en la Ensenada de Logan hay otro búnker
una impresionante catedral de concreto
reflejo de un pasado doloroso construida
por los nazis para albergar y Reparar
los subut alemanes la base de submarinos
de queroman fue durante la Segunda
Guerra Mundial una de las fortalezas
militares más grandes de Europa
necesitó un millón de metros de cemento
una base invulnerable bombardeada sin
parar por los aliados pero jamás
destruida A diferencia de la ciudad de
logian totalmente devastada
tras la guerra la base fue utilizada por
la marina francesa hasta 1997 pero hoy
en día tiene otra vocación alberga uno
de los líderes mundiales de la
fabricación de mástiles de velero en
carbono
es sorprendente pero estremece un poco
de chance que hoy estamos en un lugar
que vivió de manera diferente a pesar de
la frialdad exterior logramos hacer
cosas muy lindas adentro en este espacio
de 5000 metros cuadrados la temperatura
y la hidrometría son constantes Este
búnker es el lugar ideal para fabricar
mástiles de carbono de alto rendimiento
aquí se realizan la mayoría de los
mástiles que equipan las embarcaciones
del vendedor o la ruta de ron el mastín
más grande que hayamos hecho tiene 54
metros de largo y pesa 5 toneladas
tenemos longitudes evidentes que nos
permiten hacerle mantenimiento todavía
en Bretaña en el ingreso a la casi isla
de koson fueron excavados túneles
sorprendentes no hacen parte del muro
del Atlántico fueron elegidos por los
aliados después de la guerra y sirvieron
como lugares para esconder armas durante
decenios desde hace varios años un joven
emprendedor tuvo la idea de instalarse
en este laberinto de concreto para
fabricar cerveza
instalar una cervecería bajo tierra no
es común
entonces dije adelante instalamos la
cervecería del final del mundo
porque estamos cerca a la casi isla de
croisón y también podemos decir que
estamos casi al final del mundo aquí si
observamos la cervecería no se puede ir
más lejos cuando se está en el final se
está en el final
elaborar cerveza en lo que la gente
llama aquí los túneles de la otan es una
elección cuando menos exótica el lugar
ahora hace parte de la marca de fábrica
de la pequeña empresa sin embargo el
acondicionamiento de tal lugar necesitó
tesoros de ingeniosidad
cada problema tiene una solución pero
hay que pensar completamente distinto a
una edificación normal somos un faro
porque un subterráneo es un faro
acostado Este es un túnel grande que
llega a una sala grande ven un faro es
un gran túnel pero con altura luego
llega a esta sala grande donde está esta
gran luz es un poco lo mismo cuando se
olvida algo en el fondo hay que bajar de
nuevo aquí es lo mismo hay que salir
para regresar y puedo decirles que
recorremos algunos kilómetros
fabricar un producto de placer en un
lugar previsto inicialmente para hacer
la guerra es un palmo de narices a la
historia una manera de hacer la paz con
un patrimonio de concreto que quisimos
olvidar durante mucho tiempo